hey everyone welcome back and in this
video i want to discuss five
technologies which i'll be personally
learning this year and next year that is
2022 and why you should be learning
those technologies as well especially as
a web developer these are some of the
most important technologies you should
be aware about when you're entering next
year because these technologies are
going to be shaping the future of web
development so let's take a look at my
list of top five technologies i'll be
targeting for year 2022 also if you're
new to this channel make sure you like
and subscribe because i'll be posting a
lot of such content and if you don't
want to miss it make sure you subscribe
to the channel and hit the bell icon
this video is a part of code dam's
t-shirt giveaway program for the month
if you want to take part and win an
amazing go damn t-shirt all you have to
do is leave a comment on this video
about what you think and that's it you
are eligible if your comment gets a
heart from code damn you will win a
t-shirt for absolutely free all right so
the first and the most important
technology which i believe is going to
be at last in today's time and beyond
and there are a lot of reasons for that
first of all rust is a very popular
choice for writing code for web assembly
and webassembly is coming i mean even in
my 2021 prediction i wrote about where
the assembly is going to be getting
bigger and bigger every single year and
that is happening i mean you would see a
lot of new libraries like ffmpeg
compiled to awesome and i don't know
what else is being worked on right now
which is getting compiled to assume
which can run inside a browser so rust
is a pretty neat way to get started with
writing wasm as well because you can
compile it easily plus it's good to know
a language which operates close to the
system right and rust is memory safe it
has got a bunch of advantages over c
plus so yeah i mean rust is a solid
choice as a web developer if you want to
get into a bit of back end or maybe just
are looking for your next language and
your full stack for example link in
description for the full stack learning
path at goddamn but if you are a full
stack developer or if you are trying to
become one and you just have some time
to learn a new language i would say rust
is a really really really good option
here the second most important
technology which i'll be learning and i
believe you should be learning as well
is managed services and serverless
things on these platforms like aws
google cloud seo now why that is
important because if you're working in a
small startup or a big company as well
these products these fast growing
products require the ability to handle
the scale without actually hiring a
dedicated
devops person or a dedicated person
who's just handling the infrastructure
so in this case it is it becomes
extremely extremely easy and relevant if
you are somebody who has experience with
some sort of cloud and you are able to
set up the serverless and managed
infrastructure at least let's say you're
building a file hosting website and you
know you just want people to enable to
upload any sort of file right the best
way to do that without actually having
any headache at all is to use s3 with
something like signed urls for example
because you are standing on the
shoulders of the giant right you're
standing on the shoulders of aws so
learning about what all kind of services
can be managed cannot be managed what
are your options that is in itself super
important because it's not about
learning s3 in general it's learning
that s3 exists and what is the use case
of that it's not about learning sqs by
going to documentation and just trying
to learn everything it's more about
learning what exactly is sqs and where
you can use it's a queueing system and
how you can work with it i think some of
my favorite services which i can say
both in terms of managed and serverless
lambda is super important aws lambda i'm
just sticking with the aws tech stack
you can find equivalent and other cloud
providers s3 is extremely important sqs
is also important because once you have
a queuing system you can pretty much
create stuff which requires which might
have a lot of input in a small time
right and you can actually manage it in
a scalable way with sqs you probably
need cloud watch alarms or you know in
general also they are super helpful and
you also need to learn about i believe
is about managed databases because
databases is another part of the
application which usually people forget
to scale right because your application
can be scaled with let's say serverless
craft ql or serverless rest points but
if your database is on sitting on an ec2
instance then of course that is a that
is a bottleneck right the third
technology which i'll be looking into in
a much much detailed way is web 3.0 now
web 3.0 is has been there for a long
time which which is basically saying
decentralized web with things like
cryptocurrencies and having things like
nfps for example but actually being at a
programmer level on these things would
be super powerful and super useful for
building these decentralized apps and
having that knowledge having that not
only just programming knowledge because
well you can create an ethereum contract
by using solidity but in order to build
an application a useful application you
need to understand the whole
infrastructure and understand everything
how that works i believe like learning
about these one of these blockchains
like ethereum or solana or basically
tech stack around these blockchain based
ecosystems is also one of the things i
would be focusing a lot on next year and
would recommend you guys as well because
web 3.0 is coming it is coming i mean it
will be there in the next three to five
to seven years at max but yeah i mean
it's here to stay the fourth most
important technology which i have on my
radar is cloudflare tech stack now the
reason i say that is because i believe
cloudflare has some of the most
underrated projects right now in terms
of what they are developing one of them
is obviously the durable objects thing
which i had done a video i think in the
past as well we'll probably link it as a
card somewhere but just taking a look at
what these guys are building you would
see it's kind of like man services which
we discussed with aws and google cloud
and stuff it's at a bigger scale in the
sense it it will allow you to build real
world applications very quickly just for
an example of durable objects it's like
decentralized not exactly decentralized
but distributed storage across the world
where you just write a piece of code a
javascript code it's basically like
combining serverless but with state
right now the biggest thing which we say
is that hey in order for your
applications to be scalable your apps
should be stateless but with cloudflare
durable objects you can have a kind of a
state maintained while also keeping your
application serverless so this is
interesting right this is this is really
interesting so i would be playing and
learning more about this tech stack over
the next one year even more just to
learn about how these services can
compete with existing but a little bit
complicated solutions from aws and
google cloud and what new features
cloudflare brings in and last but not
the least i would also want to take a
look into web gpu which is a new set of
apis which will be i think is shipping
inside chrome at least in chrome 99
which is 10 to 15 weeks from this video
so once that ships there would be a way
to natively interact with gpu using just
a browser and this is not a port of
opengl like webgl it's actually built
from scratch from ground up so making
use of gpu on the web would enable a lot
of interesting use cases from 3d
rendering to i believe ml ai and model
training as well so let's see how that
works out i think this part would also
be a significant contributor of web in
today's and tomorrow's time so that is
all for my top five list of technologies
which i will be learning i know a lot of
you are still learning html css
javascript and it's fine i mean it's
fine to start with those things but know
about the ecosystem know about other
technologies in the space even if you're
not learning them actively so i hope
this video gave you a sense of what's
coming on the web and yep if you want to
watch more such videos make sure you
like the video subscribe to the channel
and hit the bell icon that is all for
this one i'm gonna see you in the next
one really soon
[Music]
you